Çeviri: Nihal Aksakal
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Her şey hayal etmekle başladı.
Hayatım boyunca,
hayallerinin peşinden koşan,
sınırları zorlayan
bir adam olmaya çalıştım.
Bu süreçte edindiğim deyimler,
tecrübeler,
bir sonraki adımı planlamam
konusunda en güzel
yönlendiriciler oldular.
Hayalim aslında,
yola çıkarken,
günün birinde bir Vosvos'umun olması,
onunla seyahat edebilmem
ve bir Rally pilotu olabilmemdi.
Hayat, anlardan
ve fırsatlardan ibarettir.
Hayatım boyunca karşıma çıkan
bütün fırsatları takip etmeye
ve zorlamaya çalıştım.
İlk fırsatım,
hayatımda karşıma çıkan ilk fırsat,
ilkokulda bir arkadaşımın
bir Pokemon fotoğrafı
getirmesiyle başladı.
O zamanlar, evlerde internet,
bilgisayar, yazıcı
çok fazla yaygın değildi.
Arkadaşım evinden çıktı aldığı fotoğrafı
bana getirdiğinde
bütün sınıf arkadaşlarımız,
okuldaki arkadaşlarımız
kendi Pokemon fotoğraflarını
bizden talep ettiler.
Aslında, iş hayatına girişim
tamamen bir Balbazar Pokemon'un
bir fotoğraf kağıdıyla başladı.
Bütün okula,
Pokemon fotoğraflarını vermemizle
satmamızla beraber
çok güzel para kazandık.
Tabi ki her işte olduğu gibi,
kısa süre sonra değişim bizi vurdu.
Önce tasolar çıktı,
daha sonra Pokemon kartları yaygınlaştı.
Pokemon kartlarının
yaygınlaşmasıyla beraber,
okuldaki herkes Pokemon
kartı topluyor,
bunların ticaretini yapıyor
ve buna çok ciddi
para harcıyorlardı.
İlk işten kazandığımız paralarla
Pokemon kartları almaya
ve bunun değiş-tokuşunu
yapmaya başladık.
O kadar ciddi para kazandık ki
her gün eve belirli bir TL,
dolar ve hatta markla dönüyordum.
Bu tabi evde ilk başta
bir reaksiyon yarattı.
Bir korku yarattı.
Ama babam finansçı olduğu için
o kazandığım paraları
değerlendirebilmem için
beni aldı bankaya götürdü
ve ilk banka hesabımı açtı.
Her gün ona danışıyor,
oradan edindiğim deneyimle
fon alıp fon satmaya başlamıştım.
Bu çok güzel bir şekilde
devam ederken,
tabii her hikâyenin
bir sonu olduğu gibi
bir son beni bekliyordu.
''Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı
okullarında ticaret yapmak yasaktır.''
diye bir uyarıyla ailem
okula davet edildi
ve ilk tabiri caizse disiplin
uyarımı aldım.
Daha sonra ise bu dönemde
çok ciddi bir para kazanmama rağmen
bu işin bir sonu oldu
ve 2001 yılında ülkemizde
Pokemon çizgi filmi
yasaklanmasıyla
bir Pokemon darbesi yaşadık
ve darbe ile beraber ilk işim
tamamen bitmiş oldu.
Bu süreç bana aslında
iki şeyi çok temelde öğretti.
1. Yaptığınız işte ne olursa olsun
her şey değişebilir.
2. Yaşadığımız ülkede, Türkiye'de,
yarın ne olacağını bilmiyoruz,
her an her şey değişebilir.
Bununla beraber,
üniversiteye kadarki süreçte,
hayatım bir çok şeyi
deneyimlemekle geçti.
İlkokulda para kazanan bir çocuksanız,
artık hayatı çok daha farklı görmeye
çok daha farklı yaşamaya başlıyorsunuz.
O günden sonra aynı çocuk,
şimdiki aynı adam olmamaya başladım.
Her zaman sınırları zorlayan,
heyecanın peşinden giden
ve hep merak eden bir adam oldum.
Üniversiteye kadar,
birçok şeyi deneyimleme fırsatım oldu.
Yelken yapmak istiyordum,
bir tersanede
bir yaz boyunca çalıştım.
Bunun karşılığında,
bir şey elde etmek için
emek vermem gerektiğini öğrendim.
Masa tenisinde, dünya ikinciliği
yaşadım milli takımda.
Aslında sınırları
zorlamayı öğrendim.
Uzun yıllar, profesyonel
basketbol oynadım.
Burs aldım, eğitim bursu aldım
ve basketbol sayesinde
takım oyuncusu olmayı öğrendim.
Kendi kısa filmimi çektim,
başka kısa filmlerde ve tiyatrolarda
yardımcı yönetmenlik yaptım.
Hayallerimi projelendirmeyi,
hayata geçirmeyi deneyimledim.
4 yıl boyunca, bir Wind Surf kulübünün
kuruluşundan itibaren bir parçası oldum.
İlk eğitmeni oldum.
Daha sonra Türkiye'deki 25 uluslararası
Wind Surf eğitmeninden biri oldum
ve o Wind Surf kulübünde,
öğrendiklerimi öğretmeyi,
paylaşmayı öğrendim.
Bu süreçler üniversiteye kadar devam etti.
Her şeyin çok başarılı
gittiğini hissetiğim,
her şeyin çok güzel
olduğunu hissettiğim dönemlerdi.
Üniversiteye girdim.
Üniversitenin başında
Öğrenci Birliği
başkanlarından biri oldum.
Sinema Kulübü'nün
kurucu başkanı oldum.
Basketbol takımının üyesi oldum.
Her şeyin çok güzel
gittiğini zannederken,
ta ki okuldan atılana kadar.
Hazırlıkta maalesef başarısız
olduğum için okuldan atıldım.
Bu benim hayatımın, aslında
bir başarısızlık zirvesi oldu.
Benimle beraber okulda aynı statüye düşen
birçok arkadaşım maalesef pes ettiler.
Ya sınava tekrardan hazırlandılar
ya başka üniversitelere
geçiş yaptılar.
Ama içimde bir şey,
beni rahatsız ediyordu.
Okulumu seviyordum,
hocalarımı seviyordum.
Aslında orada olmak istiyordum
ve pes etmek istemiyordum.
Birkaç gün sonra,
oturup bütün okulun
prosedürlerini, hazırlık prosedürlerini
YÖK'ün kanunlarını inceledim
ve bunları incelerken
yeni bir üniversite olmamızdan dolayı,
prosedürler arasında
bazı eksiklikler olduğunu fark ettim.
Bunları derledim bir sunum yaptım
ve hocamın kapısını çalıp
odasına girdim.
Dedim ki ''Beni okuldan atamazsınız.''.
Tabii ki bir gülme oldu,
''Efe'cim, o prosedürleri biz yazdık.
Herhangi bir yanlış
veya eksiklik yoktur.'' diye.
Daha sonra beni dinlediler,
çok güzel bir ekibe sunum yaptım
ve hak verdiler.
Aslında sadece okuldan atılmak
değildi beni en çok üzen.
Bu kadar yetkinliğim benden alındı.
Takımdan ayrıldım,
üniversiteye, kütüphaneye bile
girecek kartım benden alınmıştı
ve ben bunları kaybetmek istemiyordum.
O sunumdan sonra,
kurul inceledi, beni haklı buldu,
sistemi değiştirdiler,
sınav geçişleri, prosedürleri
ve ben okuldan atılmadım.
Benimle beraber daha sonra
Özyeğin Üniversitesi'nden hiçbir
öğrenci okuldan atılmadı.
Bu benim hayatımın
başarısızlık zirvesiydi,
en güzel dibe vurma anıydı.
Bu dönemde, tam okuldan
uzak kaldığım dönemde,
ilk şirketimi kurdum.
İlk şirketimi kurmakla beraber
hayallerimi devam ettirebilmek için
önümde çok güzel bir neden vardı
ama bu hikayenin
en güzel tarafı, bana göre,
ileriki yıllarda kuracağım 2.şirketimin
Melek yatırımcılarından biri
o gün kurulda sunum yaptığım
üniversite rektörümüz oldu.
Ben üniversite rektöründen yatırım alan
Türkiye'deki tek, dünyada bildiğim,
emin olmamakla beraber,
tek öğrenci oldum.
O gün yaşadığım başarısızlıkla
bir şekilde pes etseydim
belki bugün burada değildim,
başka bir kurumda, başka bir yerde,
başka bir sunum yapıyordum.
Ama o gün pes etmeyerek,
hayallerimi zorlayarak,
peşinden giderek,
aslında birçok şeyin değişebileceğini
ve takip edebileceğimi hissettim.
Bundan sonra hayat birazcık
daha farklı olmaya başladı benim için.
Kendi şirketimi kurdum.
Üniversitede, 20'li yaşlarda
bir şirket sahibi olunduğunda
dışarıdan çok havalı gözükür.
20 yaşındasınız, şirketiniz var.
İnsanlar sizi parmakla gösteriyor.
Üniversitede okurken, ortağımla
beraber ikinci şirketimizi kurduk.
2. şirketimizle beraber,
birçok global markanın,
birçok uluslararası firmanın
projelerini ve etkinliklerini
hayata geçiriyorduk ve her şey
çok güzel gidiyor gibi gözüküyordu.
Maalesef o sadece buz dağının
sadece görünen kısmıydı.
Bir gün hocamızla beraber,
İzmir'deki bir etkinliğin dönüşünde,
uçakta, kendisi ile bir
diyalog geçti aramızda.
Dedim ki ''Hocam bir tek benim mi
vergi borcum var?
Bir tek ben mi maaş ödemekte zorlanıyorum?
Bir tek ben mi kendini
başarısız hissediyorum?
Bir tek ben mi acı çekiyorum?
Etkinliklerimizde Türkiye'deki
birçok önemli iş adamını ağırlıyoruz,
birçok insanın hikâyesini dinliyoruz,
ilham alıyoruz.
Ama hiç kimse mi başarısız değil,
hiç kimse mi dibe vurmadı da
bu acıları çekmedi?
Lütfen çıkalım, bir etkinlik,
bir proje kurgulayalım
ve insanlar çıksınlar bize
başarısızlıklarını anlatsınlar.'' dedik.
Bu bizim Başarısızlık Zirvesi
adını verdiğimiz,
2012'de yaptığımız,
çok değerli bir projeydi.
Türkiye'deki birçok önemli
iş insanı o etkinliğe geldiler
ve Türkiye'de ilk kez
başarısızlıklarını anlattılar.
Nasıl bir şirket batırdıklarını, nasıl
yatırımcılarla sıkıntı yaşadıklarını,
nasıl iş kurarken
zorluk çektiklerini anlattılar
ve bu birçok kişiye ilham oldu.
Biz, üniversitede okurken
şirket sahibi olmanın dışında,
yaşadığımız birçok zorluğa rağmen
üniversiteyi bitirdik.
İki şirketi büyüttük,
iki şirketimizle beraber,
sadece Türkiye'de değil,
5 farklı ülkede 500'den fazla
projeyi hayata geçirdik
ve 2016 yılında Avrupa'nın
en iyi 100 şirketinden
biri seçildik.
Bunlar bizim hayatımızdaki
en önemli adımlardı
ama hiçbir zaman hayallerimizden
ve hayallerimizin bizi
götürdüğü yoldan vazgeçmedik.
Çıkış noktam her zaman
bir Vosvosumun olması,
onunla beraber seyahat edip
yeni yerler keşfetmek
ve günün birinde bir Rally pilotu olmaktı.
Bu benim içimdeki bir tutkuydu.
O gün, üniversite mezuniyetime
kendi sahip olduğum Vosvosumla gidebildim.
O Vosvosla beraber
birçok etkinliğe katıldım,
birçok şehri gezdim ve klasik
otomobil Rally'sinde yarıştım.
Bu yarış esnasına,
en son yakın zamanda oldu,
yarış esnasında,
Bahar Rally'sinde bir kaza geçirdik.
Geçirdiğimiz kazadan sonra
araç hasar aldı.
Bizim için de çok zordu.
Her şeye rağmen yarışı bitirdik.
Hem de derece ile bitirdik.
Dereceyle bitirmemizle beraber,
birçok insan bizim sabrımızı
ve yarışa olan tutkumuzu gördüler
ve bizimle iletişime geçtiler.
İnsanlar bizi yeni insanlarla tanıştırdı,
bize farklı network kapıları açtılar
ve bunun sayesinde ben
2.hayalim olan Rally'de yarışma için,
bu yeni insanların tanıştırdığı
şirketler, kurumlar sayesinde,
bu yıl itibariyle Türkiye Rally
Şampiyonası'nda yarışmaya başlayacağım.
Kimin size hangi kapıyı
açacağını bilemezsiniz.
Kimin size ilham olacağını bilemezsiniz.
Hangi kapının size farklı dünyalar
açacağını bilemezsiniz.
Ondan dolayı, o kapıyı çalın,
açın ve girin.
Bu sürecin içerisinde size
üç tane ana hikâye anlattım
ve bu üç ana hikâyeyi özetleyebileceğim
üç maddede toparlamak istiyorum.
Hayal kurun.
Bence ülkemizdeki en büyük problem,
çocuklarımızın, gençlerimizin
ve hatta bizlerin hayal kuramaması.
Hayal kurmakla kalmayın,
hayallerinizin peşinden gidecek
cesaretiniz olsun.
Emin olun o hayal ettiğiniz şeye
birebir sahip olamasanız da
onun bir bölümüne sahip olursunuz.
Fena mı?
Başarısız olmaktan korkmayın.
Türkiye'de böyle bir fobi var.
Gençlerle çalışıyorum,
üst düzey yöneticilerle çalışıyorum,
birçok hayata, birçok
insana dokunuyorum.
Başarısız olmaktan korkmayın.
Kalkın, deneyin, düşün.
Kalkın, tekrar deneyin.
Ne olacak, ne kaybedeceksiniz?
Denemeden kaybedeceğiniz
şeyi bilemezsiniz. Deneyin.
Bir şekilde, hayatınızın
hikayesini yazmaya başlayın.
Bulunduğunuz koltuktan kalkın,
kendi sahnenize gidin
ve bana göre hayat anlardan
ve fırsatlardan ibarettir.
Hayatınızdaki o anı yaşayın,
o anı paylaşın.
Fırsatların fırsat olduğunu
denemeden bilemezsiniz.
O kapıyı çalmadan,
o kapıdan içeri girmeden
onun fırsat olduğunu
hiçbir zaman bilemeyeceksiniz.
Lütfen o kapıyı çalın, içeri girin.
Çok sevdiğim bir sözle aslında
bu hikâyeyi bitirmek istiyorum.
Hayali bir Rally pilotu olmak
isteyen bir çocuğun
söyleyebileceği aslında en güzel söz:
''Eğer yeteri kadar her şey
kontrol altındaysa,
demek ki yeteri kadar
hızlı gitmiyorsunuzdur.''
Çok teşekkür ederim.